all rich people inherited their wealth
lie all rich people got that way by
being crooks lie all rich people are
entertainers actors professional
athletes rock stars lie by the way that
is less than 1% of America's
millionaires all rich people are
brilliant they have high GPAs lie
average GPA of the ones I talked to and
including me is around a 3.0 they're not
getting 1.2 s but they're not 4.2 people
either some of them are but on average
we're not most rich people read more
than watching television and that's
nonfiction books by the way I read
fiction too and I do have a nice
television but I just can't stand
watching it all the time
especially the network stuff it's Jimmy
football and an occasional news show and
that's pretty well maybe a movie every
now and then but that's about it it's
just very seldom on at our house we just
have we're just weird we just sit and
read I said make it sold no cuz we start
doing that when we were young it made us
wealthy because knowledge does that
so all this mythology out there that
you've done something wrong in the rich
or somehow different than you they're
not they're not matter of fact I'm so
dumb I had to do it twice I became a
millionaire by the time I was 28 then
lost everything because I'd borrowed so
much money I'm stupid so if you are a
millionaire this is a millionaire theme
our we want to talk to real millionaires
and not tell lies but tell the truth
what how did you really do it what's
really going on so that those of you
that aren't yet millionaires can learn
how to do it we'll take your call if you
are a millionaire right now the phone
number is triple eight eight two five
five two two five triple eight eight two
five five two two five
if you have a 1 million dollar or
greater net worth we want to interview
you Patty's on the line from Akron Ohio
hi Patti how are you I'm great Dave how
are you better than I deserve what's
your net worth just above a million not
a million cool you did it mm-hmm
and how old are you how old are you I'm
I'm 62 and my husband's 65 got it cool
and what's the one million invested in
we have about a third of it is real
estate our house and then we have a
couple of rental properties and the rest
of it is you know either 401k or outside
the 401k and mutual funds gotcha
all right oh cool and how much of the 1
million did you inherit a very minimal
of that and that's just been very recent
so I don't really you know count that
gotcha cool and I mean what's minimal I
got ten thousand or a hundred thousand I
know like a hundred yeah okay yeah but
you got that in the last little bit so
you're already there yeah yeah exactly
yeah and what's been your average house
what's been the range of your household
income throughout your working life you
know Dave we we probably started out
around you know 40,000 and got as high
as in the two to hundreds and then now
we're you know at a little over 100
hundred and fifteen something like that
what were your career so my husband is a
retired teacher and I'm still working
I'm administrator of a nonprofit that's
right all right cool
I won't we're degrees in education and
yeah this is education and I have an MBA
gotcha
and now and your GPAs I think this is
about a three oh and mine was about a
three eight okay well I know who's
smarter yeah so so how much of this
million-dollar net worth is there
because you used borrowed money to build
wealth
well we didn't we did a little bit of
that at the very beginning but that as
you know doesn't really build wealth
I'll tell you what we did and one of the
reasons that I wanted to talk to you
Dave I think some of the best advice you
give to younger people is to choose a
good college an affordable college and
to choose a career that's going to be
employable and meaningful that's for us
when we got married and started having
children we didn't have education and so
one of the things that we did that
changed our trajectory so to speak is
that we went back and got our education
and we started with me because I had a
little more under my belt in terms of I
have a year or two and I went at night
and took care of the four kids during
the day and he worked the day and took
care of the kids at night and then once
I got my degree and got employed at a
job that had benefits then we switched
no and so you know if we had started
this at you know 25 and 28 instead of
you know 32 and 36 we'd have double what
we have but the key thing is that we
started I think and I'm in I guess
you know when you say what's your
message to younger people it's like it's
never really too late because it
definitely benefited us more than heavy
you know continued doing what we were
doing so that's been you know what part
has given Lee what part is giving played
in your financial plan through these
years well it it's always played a part
even when we didn't have you know the
resources that we have but obviously now
it's much much easier and much better
and much broader than it was in the past
were able to do it in a number of ways
through you know I'm involved in a
non-profit with children with serious
illness so we devote a lot to children
with serious illnesses production you
know just able to even work and do
things that don't perhaps have the same
compensation because
because we can watch the back in those
kind of ways
yeah what's the most expensive pair of
jeans you ever bought I think about 40
bucks okay and how many new cars have
you guys bought in your life we've
bought a couple new cars and then we
drive them until they fall apart gotcha
okay and what how many non-fiction books
do you guys read on a year average
probably I'd say one a month okay what's
the best thing you've read an on Dave
Ramsey in the last 1224 months
you know I just reading this not
nonfiction but I just read the
Underground Railroad Oh which which was
a really excellent book and and I like
memoirs so you know I've been reading up
catching up with things like wild and
the $64 tomato about how you know
sometimes the effort to save money can
cost you money so interesting okay very
cool well thank you for calling in your
great American success story
how's it feel it feels great it's just a
it's a tremendous feeling of comfort I
hear you
well congratulations very proud of you
very very well done hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show you can do this you
know that really is a message whether
you've got two hundred seventy thousand
dollars in student loan debt or 27
thousand well you've got a fifty
thousand dollar income or $500,000 in
common